this week we're going to study the
physics of baking baking has arisen
already on several occasions in this
course but so far we haven't been able
to actually go into the physics of
baking that is how do recipes for baked
goods work and produce the delicious
outcomes that we all so much enjoy and
the reason for that the reason that we
haven't discussed baking as of yet is
that as you will see this week the
physics of baking involves many in fact
it's not most of the ideas that we've
discussed up until this point
baking involves elasticity viscosity of
motions heat transfer solubility many
concepts like that and this week we're
going to go through what is going to be
on one hand a bit of a review of the
concepts that we've discussed up until
this point and the other hand we're
going to show you how these ideas apply
to baking so before we begin I just want
to give one caveat we are not
professional Baker's we are scientists
and our intent of this week's baking
discussion is not to basically go
through every method and every technique
that is required to basically make a
baked delicious what we're going to do
is to expose the basic scientific issues
that underlie baking and by putting them
together in your own mind they will
hopefully help you make sense of recipes
and to help us with this we're very
fortunate to be able to visit the
kitchen of Joanne Chang a flower bakery
hi I'm Joanne Chang a flower bakery I'm
going to be showing you today how to
make yellow birthday cake and talking to
you about all of the science behind
making birthday cakes so first let me
show you all the ingredients we have for
a yellow birthday cake
we have unsalted butter granulated sugar
we have eggs and egg yolks and there's a
little bit of vanilla in here as well we
also have some buttermilk and then our
dry ingredients which are flour
and then in this container are combined
baking soda baking powder and kosher
salt okay the first thing I do is I'm
going to put the butter into a mixer you
can do this by hand but I promise you
after about 10 minutes your arm to be
really tired so if you can do it a mixer
now one of the things that's important
about the butter is that we want it to
be at room temperature now why is it
important that the butter is at room
temperature because what we're going to
be doing is we're going to be adding
millions and millions of minuscule
microscopic air pockets into the butter
and we're going to do that with our
sugar the imagine sugar it's an actual
crystal right sugar is a is a crystal
and the crystalline structure of the
sugar what it does is it acts as tiny
little shovels into the butter and it
digs all of these little holes and makes
little minuscule pockets of air if the
butter is too cold then the sugar can't
do its work the shovel just aren't
strong enough so you want to make sure
you start off with room-temperature
butter I'm going to slowly start adding
the sugar and as I'm doing this the
butter is slowly starting to get more
and more work work up
and I'm going to show this to you once
all of the butter gets its put in now
why is it so important that I have all
of these air pockets so if you imagine
what you want to the ideal birthday cake
you want something that's nice and light
and fluffy and tender and velvety and
the last thing in the world you want is
a really tough hard to eat
chewy cake what we try to do in the
making of the cake is create as many
opportunities as possible for science to
do with magic and take all of these
ingredients and turn them into something
light and fluffy and delicious so when I
talk about the sugar creating air
pockets into the butter
later on life actually added all of
these ingredients to the cake batter and
I put that batter into the oven all of
those pockets of air will expand in the
oven once they get into the key to the
oven and that is what's going to help
cause some of the rise of the cake and
the rise of the cake is going to make
the cake really light and fluffy instead
of heavy and dense